[Music]
you are in incredible shape and I'm just
wondering I have three boys and you you
like basketball
you know the zone versus man-to-man yes
we are on a zone defense and if I don't
I have to honestly stay like one push up
ahead of them
one head stand ahead of them because
they will kill me see that's what it's
it's funny my wife and I we have two so
we're a man-to-man we each take one kid
you're saying once there's a third
you've got to just be ready for anything
plus it's all dudes so I mean god bless
men I love them as I just invited them
all in just did yeah there are a certain
age they're not the brightest bulbs yeah
yeah they're constantly doing
death-defying things they're leaping off
of fireplaces and they they want to harm
you yes and they want to earn themselves
yes so I have to I mean quite quite
literally stay ahead of them now I'm
curious what's it like because you are
the only woman in an all-male I mean
you've got your husband you've got these
three boys that's an interesting dynamic
yeah well it's a little bit like being
um like the the the lobster boy in the
freak show because any opportunity the
little chickies
you completely lost me you know you know
what it's like being a mom you're the
lobster boy in the freakshow
that they can't any opportunity to sneak
in not my husband again but the kids
just sneak in when I'm taking a shower
something and just sort of stare and
wonder where it is or what's wrong with
that they feel bad for me like I'm a
freak oh because you're different
yes I'm lady business and they think
that that's that's but by the same token
they all if there is a return to the
womb that's constantly they all just
want to get get back inside somehow I
invite the home viewer to rewind and you
will see that I invited none of this
I have very innocent questions about
how's your children you look like you're
in great shape and then you took us I
know
journey into my uterus which I really
did not intend I say though I have seen
this myself no not OK
there was one time no my with my wife
I've seen the the boy my son just the
boy the boy I'll find his name's out
someday you know what my agent knows
what it is
no but he's constantly going up to my
wife Liza and literally picking up her
shirt and sticking his head underneath
and like I just want to hang out in
there how old's the boy he's 41 no he's
fine he's it's true it started when he
was that's the thing is it starts when
they're like five four or five where
they just want to climb up in there yes
and then they hang out there for a
couple of years and then you think at a
certain point when he's in his 20s I'm
gonna have to say you you know you must
leave that area I have terrible news for
you I quit sooner than the 20s I think
it's like 13 they get confused what I
I'm not a boy we've established that
well we established that but there's
guys I'm confused about we're trying to
get inside cuddling snuggling mommy
mommy hand inside the shirt just holding
the boob casually because that's what we
do and then there's like doesn't
something like the hormone click and
you're like laughs no
I'm still as an isn't it eat as it as a
middle-aged man I'm still constantly
reaching for boob all the time not your
mom
[Music]
what are you gonna do you know slow
weekend okay here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna take a break